la crise est de retour au Congrès des
mers le 76e du nom en Indre-et-Loire
après celle du covid voici celle de
l'énergie les 272 et d'îles réduit à se
demander comment ils vont payer la
facture alors face au ministre Gabriel
Attal ils ont réclamé un nouveau coup de
pouce financier le reportage au Palais
des Congrès de Tours de Sébastien
Branger
sac en bandouillet les mers sont venus
le pas décidé demandé des comptes à
l'état en effet le filet de sécurité
énergétique mise en place cet été par le
gouvernement semble insuffisant et mal
réparti sur proposition de l'Association
des maires de France le gouvernement a
commencé à répondre partiellement à une
aide qui s'appelle le filet de sécurité
manque de pot sur l'Indre-et-Loire ce ne
sont que 82 communes qui sont éligibles
272 toutes les communes sont marquées
par cette crise donc elles doivent être
impérativement aider donc c'est